people are just excited to go into this
building to see Jokes which I feel like
is very rare oh yeah yeah it's awesome I
mean if if you're a comedy fan you got
you have to come to the mother ship at
least once yeah you know I think that's
what a lot of people are doing but also
if you a if you're a comedian you got to
come to the mother ship at least once
it's the only Club where all the money
goes into the club every other Comedy
Club has to survive and the mothership
don't have to do that we all see those
pictures of the uh the red neon don't be
a sign and that cool snake table
and all that stuff how how dope is
actually being in that green room and
hanging out with people oh man it's
amazing honestly man I laugh more in
that green room than I do anywhere else
I guess that is a that is a a little a
little uh a little taste that most
people don't get to to experience but no
it's it's amazing it's it's one of the
nice nicest green rooms I've been in for
sure